in the nationwide protests over George
Floyd's death one city stands out Newark
New Jersey was nearly burned to the
ground during civil-rights Arab riots 53
years ago but last week thousands
spilled into the streets and everyone
the police the community and young
people all work together to keep the
peace Michelle Miller spoke to Newark's
mayor before she went to Houston to
cover Floyd's funeral Michelle good
morning again good morning well raspberr
akka was elected mayor of Newark in 2014
and has been fighting to reform the
city's police department ever since
crime in Newark is down so are payouts
for police brutality cases the mayor
told us those accomplishments weren't
his work alone the residents of this
city are proud raspberr akka is the
mayor of Newark New Jersey's largest
city in masking gloves he's leading his
hometown out of the kovat pandemic and
now he's navigating this national
reckoning on race five days after the
death of George Floyd more than ten
thousand people poured into the streets
but unlike other cities Newark suffered
no fires no looting either what you can
find on the streets of Newark dancing
our kids singing in the street is enough
to drive the white supremacist my
[Applause]
massive protest in Newark police did not
make a single arrest how did that happen
the police showed incredible restraint
during the margin and during the evening
four years ago the City of Newark
negotiated an agreement with the
Department of Justice to reform its
Police Department officers are trained
differently now they have you know all
kinds of sensitivity training
de-escalation training this is a black
City for the most part it is a city that
has seen rebellion unrest disappointment
in the past so right now in our Police
Department is my is majority minority so
the majority of police officers are
black and brown many of them now come
from the city of noir we made a
concerted and deliberate effort to do
that
complaints against Newark police are
down more than 70% and a show of how
closely the mayor works with his cops
last week Mayor Baraka went with his gut
and said let us all take a deal the
police chief said his side was followed
suit some folks say taking a knee as a
sign of weakness you say I say it's a
sign of strength I think it takes a lot
of strength to restrain yourself right
it takes a lot of strength to discipline
yourself there's something about that
that people need to understand community
organizer Larry Hamm spearheaded the
Newark protests working closely with
Mayor Baraka we found him this past
weekend in neighboring Montclair we have
to deconstruct and reconstruct policing
as we know it in the United States your
biggest roadblock the police unions
unless they know that if they murder a
man they're going to be charged they're
going to be prosecuted when they know
that then they'll be hesitant about
taking someone's life like George
Floyd's life was taken we haven't had
any riots I'm shocked I predict their
riots for this city college student
Davion Johnson told us that he attended
the protest to fight injustice but that
would only come by keeping the peace
only reason I'm not radical right now
throwing trash cans out windows their
wallet it's because I'm I understand I
understand that's not the way to go I
understand history we can't be taking
this violent direction it makes no sense
it's a means to an end
they did it they held a lot my hat's off
to them where do you go from here to
Buster now you're not gonna be as angry
as you were as you are today right but
your commitment your love of community
of humanity is enduring and two months
from now those emotions will remain in
fact over time love gets stronger you
really believe that absolutely knowing
it's worth remembering the during
protests back in 1967 Mayor Baraka
father was severely beaten by a police
officer and a bit of news the mayor
announced just yesterday that he is
reallocating about 12 million dollars of
the police budget to anti-violence
programs jail boy Michelle it looks like
many cities could take some notes from
Mayor Baraka the scene that you showed
with the mayor and all the police
officers that we saw kneeling down was
very very powerful to see and Bravo to
young Debbie on to said you got to know
your history and something else Evian
said to me that is striking me that
Allah he is asking young people people
of all ages and stripes to vote in
November for every YES on the ballot yes
yes agree agree agree and one other
thing I noticed listen you never go
wrong with an electric slide and the
cupid shuffle I've been known to trample
little children to get to the dance
floor to do that it just makes you feel
good no matter where you are the picture
is they don't act like Michelle you
don't know what that is doing the
electrics level Michelle Miller thank
you very much